the very first thing joe biden did when
he got to the white house was to change
the mission of the us immigration and
customs enforcement agency ice the bite
administration decided to protect
criminals from deportation not because
there was a groundswell of support for
having foreign nationals who were felons
in our country but because they wanted
to change the country and they are
so ice was instructed not to arrest most
illegal aliens including many convicted
felons and naturally deportations
plummeted tonight we have exclusive
reporting on what is actually happening
inside ice which is a government agency
that you pay for
now we spoke to a now former senior ice
official thomas feeley who said he'd
never seen anything like this in the 25
years he worked there
feely retired because the bite
administration's refusal to enforce the
law he told us last week that activists
who don't work for the government but
for creepy left-wing non-profits
routinely weigh in and stop deportations
that seem incredible to us doesn't even
sound legal
why would an ngo have control over u.s
government policy but in fact it's
happening and we can prove it this show
has just obtained internal ice emails
confirming feely's claim
on june 7th an activist contacted ice
asking for an urgent favor the activist
is a woman called tonya matos she's a
member of abolish ice the movement that
wants to end any border control
whatsoever
now matos demanded that ice order a stay
of removal that would block the
deportation of a convicted felon called
marvin gerasanio pena that was set to
take place within 24 hours pena's
criminal record included robbery and
simple assault and drug charges
a federal immigration judge ordered
payne you removed from the country back
in july of last year because why would
people like that stay why would you ever
import criminals especially in the
middle of a crime spike which we're
living through now
but matos didn't care and wanted ice to
overlook that ruling so she emailed an
ice attorney asking for quote assistance
on the case of marvin jerezinho pena
just 20 minutes after she sent that
email the ice lawyer forwarded to tim
perry that's isis chief of staff and
said it's quote a time sensitive matter
because when abolished ice activists
demand action
ice acts
so perry deemed that request so
important that he requested his staff
produce a report on pina then discussed
the activist request on a call with ice
director tay johnson he forwarded the
criminal report to johnson and said this
quote i mentioned this on our call
earlier sharing
johnson responded quote gents can we
grant a 14-day stay of removal on this
end quote an official responded will do
this is what they're doing
as the border has descended into total
chaos a hellish scene of human suffering
our country is being invaded by the rest
of the world not just mexico not just
latin america the whole world
and they're worried about how they can
keep a felon in our country without you
knowing about it and they're doing it
based on a single email from an activist
who wants ice to be eliminated so the
director of vice decides to protect a
convicted criminal illegal from
deportation
can this be real
i mean it looked real so he reached out
to ice for comment and yes it is real
they did not dispute a reporting they
confirmed that pena has not been
deported he's still in our country
a spokesman told us that ice quote
routinely works alongside
non-governmental organizations crazy
left-wing ones that hate america
so the bite administration is not
working with activists from places like
fair that want criminals deported it's
working with the abolish ice movement
which now has control over ice
it's insane they no longer have to
eliminate ice they're in charge of it
how is this happening does nobody care
how many convicted felons are still in
this country because of people like this
why is the bite administration allowing
this why are we putting up with it and
where are republicans in congress what
are they doing oh voting for pete but a
judge's infrastructure bill 19 of them
today
someone needs to stand up for the
country and do it right away